الأردن موطن لـ 40% من إجمالي
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين المسجلين في
الشرق الأوسط وفقًا للأمم المتحدة، وهو
ببساطة عدد ضخم خاصة بالنسبة
لبلد صغير. ملكة الأردن رع هي
نفسها من أصل فلسطيني
وتنضم إلي الآن في عالم حصري
من أمان  العاصمة الملكة ريا مرحباً
بك في برنامجنا، شكراً لك أيها المسيحي، هل يمكنني أن أسألك
أولاً كعربي كفلسطيني
كإنسان وأم، كيف
تشعر منذ
7 أكتوبر، حسناً، انظر يا مسيحي، لا أستطيع أن أبدأ
في وصف عمق هذا الشعور لك.
الحزن والألم وأه الصدمة أه
التي نشعر بها هنا في الأردن
كلنا متحدون في هذا الحزن
بغض النظر عن أصلنا أه نحن
فقط لا نستطيع أن نصدق الصور التي
نراها كل يوم تخرج  من أننا
نذهب للنوم ونرى تلك الصور
ونستيقظ عليها، كما تعلمون، لا
أعرف كيف تعلمون كأم أننا رأينا
أمهات فلسطينيات اضطررن إلى
كتابة أسماء أطفالهن على
أيديهن  لأن فرص
تعرضهم للقصف حتى الموت
وتحول أجسادهم إلى جثث مرتفعة للغاية، كما
تعلمون، أريد فقط أن أذكر العالم
بأن الأمهات الفلسطينيات يحببن
أطفالهن تمامًا مثل أي
أم أخرى في العالم وعليهن أن
يرحلن.  من خلال هذا أمر لا يصدق
وأعتقد أن الناس في جميع أنحاء أه الشرق الأوسط
بما في ذلك الأردن نشعر
بالصدمة وخيبة الأمل من
رد فعل العالم على هذه الكارثة
التي تتكشف في الأسبوعين الماضيين، لقد
رأينا أنك تعرف
معايير مزدوجة صارخة  أه في العالم عندما
حدث 7 أكتوبر العالم
على الفور وبشكل لا لبس فيه أه وقف
إلى جانب إسرائيل وأه من حق الدفاع عن
نفسه وأدان أه الهجوم الذي
حدث ولكن عندما نرى ما نشهده في
الأسابيع القليلة الماضية لدينا نحن
رؤية الصمت في العالم أم تعلم أن
الدول توقفت عند مجرد
التعبير عن القلق أو الاعتراف
بالضحايا ولكن دائما بمقدمة
إعلان الدعم أه لإسرائيل وكما
تعلم هل يقال لنا إنه من
الخطأ قتل عائلة عائلة بأكملها
تحت تهديد السلاح ولكن لا بأس أن نقصفهم
حتى الموت. أعني أن هناك
معايير مزدوجة صارخة هنا، وهو أمر
صادم للعالم العربي، فهذه هي
المرة الأولى في التاريخ الحديث التي توجد فيها
مثل هذه المعاناة الإنسانية والعالم
لا يدعو حتى إلى ذلك.  وقف إطلاق النار، لذا فإن
الصمت يصم الآذان، وبالنسبة للكثيرين في
منطقتنا، فهو يجعل العالم الغربي
متواطئًا، كما تعلمون من خلال
دعمهم ومن خلال الغطاء الذي
يقدمونه لإسرائيل بأنه من حقها
الدفاع عن نفسها، كما ينظر الكثيرون في العالم العربي.
العالم الغربي لا
يتسامح مع هذا فحسب، بل يساعده
ويحرض عليه، وهذا أمر
مروع بالنسبة لنا، وهو أمر مخيب
للآمال بشدة لنا جميعًا الملكة آر،
سأطلب منك المزيد حول هذا و و و و
و للتعمق أكثر  في هذا، أه، أنت
تعرف مشاعرك حول هذا
ولكن أولاً أريد أن أسألك، هل تعلم أن
الإسرائيليين مصدومون حتى النخاع من
الحزن، كما تعلم أن
ما حدث لهم لم يحدث أبدًا
بهذه الطريقة منذ المحرقة  وهم
مهتزون حتى النخاع كما قلت والحزن
أريد فقط أن أحصل منك على
ما شعرت به في
7 أكتوبر جيدًا بالطبع لقد صدمت وأنت تعلم أن
الأردن قد أوضح موقفه تمامًا
فنحن ندين قتل أي
مدني سواء  فلسطيني أو أو إسراء
هذا هو موقف الأردن الأخلاقي والمعنوي وهو
أيضا موقف
الإسلام الإسلام يدين أه قتل
المدنيين كما ذكر زوجي
مؤخرا أه الحلف العمري الذي
صدر على أبواب القدس
قبل 15 قرنا أه أي 10000 سنة
قبل اتفاقيات جنيف تأمر
المسلمين بعدم إيذاء عدم قتل
امرأة أو طفل أو كبير كبير في السن
وعدم أه تدمير شجرة أو أو أو
أو إيذاء كاهن ولذلك هذا ما
نعتقده قواعد الاشتباك
في وقت  الحرب لكن يجب أن تنطبق على
الجميع فنعم كانت هناك الصدمة وهناك
الإدانة ولكن لماذا لا تكون
هناك إدانة متساوية لما
يحدث الآن أريد فقط التأكيد على
أن أه ما حدث أه في أكتوبر هذا
الصراع لم يبدأ في  السابع من تشرين الأول (أكتوبر)
على الرغم من أنه تم تصويره على أنه كما
تعلمون فإن معظم الشبكات تغطي
القصة تحت عنوان "إسرائيل في حالة
حرب"، لكن بالنسبة للعديد من الفلسطينيين على
الجانب الآخر من الجدار العازل على
الجانب الآخر من الأسلاك الشائكة،
لم تترك الحرب هذا أبدًا.  هي قصة عمرها 75 سنة
قصة موت
وتهجير غامر للشعب الفلسطيني
هي قصة احتلال في ظل
نظام أرت الذي يحتل الأرض التي أم
يهدم البيوت
يصادر الأراضي أه توغلات عسكرية
غارات ليلية تعرف سياق
النووي  القوة العظمى الإقليمية المسلحة التي
تحتل وتضطهد وترتكب
جرائم يومية موثقة ضد الفلسطينيين
مفقودة من السرد الملكة التي
تعرفها منذ فترة طويلة عن حياة الفلسطينيين أنا
آسف لمقاطعتك أريد أن أسألك
سؤالاً محددًا لأنك تستخدم
الكثير من الكلمات  ومن الواضح أن الكثير منكم، كما
تعلمون في العالم العربي، قد
استخدموا كلمات مثل الفصل العنصري والبقية
ولكنك تعلم أنك ستتعرض
للكثير من الانتقادات من إسرائيل
ومؤيديها وأنا أتساءل عما إذا
كنت ستخرج إلى  أتكلم ولكن اسمحوا لي
فقط أن أؤكد ولكن اسمحوا لي فقط أن أؤكد على
أن هذه التسمية "الفصل العنصري" هي تسمية
لم يُعطها العرب بل منظمات
حقوق الإنسان الإسرائيلية والدولية التي
كتبتها في
قصة على إنستغرام في الأسبوع الماضي فقط، فهذا ليس
دفاعًا عن النفس إذا  أنت
قوة احتلال وتظهر الدمار الذي لحق
بغزة وقد نشرت مقطع فيديو
لنفسك من الظالم في عام 2009 أثناء
تلك الحرب أه تقول إنه من المفجع
أن نرى مدى ضآلة التغيير في العالم
لا يمكن أن تظل صامتًا، هذا يجب أن
يتوقف عن القيام به  تشعر أن لديك
صوتًا خاصًا تعرفه كملكة
الأردن في بلد لديه
معاهدة سلام مع إسرائيل
للتحدث، الأمر لا يتعلق بي، بل يتعلق بالتحدث باسم
الإنسانية، تعلم أن هذا لا
يتعلق بكونك مؤيدًا لـ-  الإسرائيلي أو
المؤيد أه الفلسطيني هذا يتعلق
باختيار الناس الناس العاديين
على كلا الجانبين وأنت تعلم
وتوضح مرة أخرى أن
الشعب الفلسطيني يعيش منذ فترة طويلة
تحت القمع
والتجريد من الإنسانية كما تعلم أه أنه
يعاني من الإهانات اليومية والإنسانية
انتهاكات الحقوق سواء كانوا
مسجونين أو مذلين أو مضايقين
ليس لديهم حرية التنقل أه
هناك أكثر من 500 حاجز أه منتشرة في
جميع أنحاء الضفة الغربية لديك
حرب انفصال تعتبر غير شرعية
من قبل محكمة العدل الدولية
التي فصلت المناطق  إلى
200 جيب منفصل، وأنت تعلم
أنك رأيت التوسع العدواني
للمستوطنات على الأراضي الفلسطينية، وقد
قطعت تلك المستوطنات
التواصل الإقليمي للمناطق
واعتبرت أن
الدولة الفلسطينية المستقلة المستقلة غير قابلة للحياة، لذا فإنك
ترى كل هذه هي الخلفية
في هذا الصراع هناك
تركيز كبير على حماس الآن بسبب
ما حدث في
الأسبوعين الماضيين أه لكن هذه مشكلة
تسبق حماس بكثير وستستمر بعد
حماس هذا كفاح من أجل الحرية
والعدالة وهذا ما  ما الذي يجب
سماعه، هل يمكنني أن أطرح عليك هذا السؤال
إذًا لأنك تعرف أمًا شجاعة جدًا،
وأعتقد أنها سعودية على أي حال، أخذ أحد
الصحفيين في شبكة التلفزيون السعودية "
العربية" هذا الكلام وضرب
خالد مشعل الرئيس السابق لحركة
حماس وقال له  "المجزرة" حسنًا،
هذه كلمتي لكنها قالت إن ما
يراه الجميع على شاشاتهم هل
تعلم أنه قد أدى إلى تحويل العالم بعيدًا عن القضية
الفلسطينية وفقط لتوسيع
الناس يقولون حماس وما فعلته
قد أسقط هذا على هؤلاء الفقراء
في غزة، أليس كذلك؟  تقبل
ذلك جيدًا، وأعتقد أنني لا أؤمن بما
قلته في قتل
المدنيين ولكن هذه قصة
عنف مستمرة الآن لفترة
طويلة ويجب إدانة هذا العنف
ولكن في نهاية الأمر  إن ما
نشهده اليوم وما يحتاج الناس
إلى فهمه هو أنه نعم، تحت
ستار الحق في الدفاع عن
نفسها، فإننا نشهد فظائع كما تعلم
أن كل دولة لها الحق في الدفاع عن
نفسها ولكن ليس من خلال أي وسيلة وليس
من خلالها.  جرائم الحرب ليست من خلال
العقاب الجماعي، كما تعلمون،
قتل 6000 شخص مدنيين حتى الآن 2400
طفل، كيف يتم هذا الدفاع عن النفس الذي
نشهده، مذبحة على نطاق واسع باستخدام
أسلحة دقيقة، كما تعلمون، لقد
رأينا خلال الأسبوعين الماضيين
قصف عشوائي أه غزة أم
عائلات بأكملها مسحت
أحياء سكنية سويت بالأرض
استهداف المستشفيات والمدارس
والكنائس و و والمساجد
والعاملين في المجال الطبي صحفيين أه
عمال الإغاثة كيف يكون ذلك دفاعا عن النفس أنت
تعرف لماذا هو لماذا هو ذلك  كلما
ارتكبت إسرائيل هذه الفظائع، فإنها تأتي
تحت شعار الدفاع عن النفس، ولكن
عندما يكون هناك عنف من قبل
الفلسطينيين، فإنه يُطلق عليه
على الفور اسم الإرهاب، وهي
كلمة إرهابية مخصصة
حصريًا للمسلمين والعرب، حسنًا،
دعني أسأل، هناك معايير مزدوجة حقيقية
هنا نحن  'إنك ترى
تماثل زوجك FSE الذي نراه حسنًا، دعني
أسألك هذا زوجك الملك عبد الله
لأن هذين ليسا
شخصين في الصراع، فأنت تعرف أن أحدهما
محتل والآخر محتل، والآخر
لديه جيش من أقوى القوات في العالم
العالم والآخر ليس لديهما
ميل عسكري على الإطلاق، لذلك هناك
تماثل زائف هنا يتم رسمه وهناك
أيضًا كما تعلم عندما تقول
الحق في الدفاع عن نفسه الذي لا يقول
القصة بأكملها، فهو لا يقولها
قصة انتهاك
القانون الدولي القانون الدولي الإنساني
لا تروي لك المعاناة
وأه قصة احتلال
تعرفه إسرائيل تنتهك ما لا يقل عن
30 قرارا أمنيا للأمم المتحدة
تلزمها وحدها بالتحرك
الانسحاب من الأراضي المحتلة عام
1967 لوقف الاستيطان
والجدار العازل وانتهاكات حقوق الإنسان،
هذا هو جوهر هذه
القضية، ليس هذا التركيز المفرط على
حماس، هل يمكنني أن أطلب منك أن تعرف نوعاً ما من
التفصيل لأن زوجك الملك
عبد الله أعتقد  لقد قال الأسبوع الماضي
في قمة الزعماء العرب في القاهرة إن
الرسالة التي يسمعها العالم العربي
هي بصوت عال وواضح أن
حياة الفلسطينيين أقل أهمية من حياة الإسرائيليين،
حياتنا أقل أهمية من حياة الآخرين،
أعلم أنك قلت الكثير عنك، كما تعلم
مشاعرك تجاه ما يحدث
الآن ولكن هل تعتقد بشكل عام
أن هذا صحيح أنه حتى زعماء العالم
وغيرهم وأنت تقابل الكثير منهم
وكذلك يفعل الملك ولهذا السبب
قال إنني
أفترض جيدًا كما قلت أنك تعلم  لقد
كان مخيبا للآمال للغاية أن نرى
ازدواجية المعايير في العالم في
العالم اليوم لنرى أنكم تعرفون
الإدانة القوية لما حدث
في 7 أكتوبر ولكن إدانة قليلة للغاية
لما يحدث اليوم
لماذا لا توجد دعوة ل  وقف فوري
لإطلاق النار نرى
معاناة إنسانية مذهلة تحدث اليوم تعرفون لماذا
الرواية تنحرف دائما نحو
الجانب الإسرائيلي تعلمون أه
الإعلام الغربي وصناع السياسة يسارعون
إلى تبني الروايات الإسرائيلية
عندما عندما تهاجم إسرائيل
يموت الفلسطينيون ولكن عندما  يموت الإسرائيليون ويُطلق عليهم
اسم "القتلى" بدم بارد، إنها
مجزرة، فحتى كما حدث في 7 أكتوبر رأينا
أه الوضع الموصوف
بالوحشية والهمجية المتعطشة للدماء وبدم
بارد، كما تعلمون، لكننا لا
نرى أن المصطلحات لا
تصف الوضع اليوم حتى
على الرغم من أن الفظائع ذات
حجم أكبر، فأنا لا أجادل في الدقة يا
كريستيان، بل أجادل في التكافؤ
والمعايير المزدوجة هنا عندما
يتم إخبار رئيس الولايات المتحدة
أنك تعلم أن لديه أدلة على أنه
رأى أدلة على قطع رؤوس الأطفال
ثم يتراجع عن ذلك.  لأن الجيش الإسرائيلي قال
إنه لا يوجد دليل على أن هذا هو
تحيز تأكيدي حتى في شبكتك
المسيحية، كما تعلم موقع CNN
أه في بداية الصراع
نشر عنوانًا رئيسيًا لأطفال إسرائيليين
تم العثور عليهم مذبوحين في كابوت إسرائيلي
وعندما تقرأ من خلال  القصة
هناك لم يتم التحقق منها بشكل مستقل
الآن سؤالي لك هل
ستنشر مثل هذا الادعاء اللعين الذي لم يتم
التحقق منه والذي قدمته فلسطينية أم
الملكة ريا أنا فقط بحاجة إلى إيقافك
هناك لأنه كانت هناك
صور معروضة بواسطة  لقد
كان الإسرائيليون والصحفيون لدينا هناك،
أنا لا أتحدث عن قطع الرؤوس، أنا
أتحدث عن أجساد الأطفال المليئة
بالرصاص والأشياء، لكن دعونا
ندع الأمر كله
فظيع للغاية كما تقول، أريد أن أسألك
بخصوص ما قاله الأردن
وزوجك الملك قال أن هناك على
أية حال كانت هناك محاولة أو
اقتراح للتحرك أه لنقل
الفلسطينيين الذين يحاولون
البحث عن الأمان إما في مصر
أو في الأردن في بلدك و  وقد
قال الملك أن هذا خط أحمر
وأعتقد أن الخطة التي وضعها بعض
المشتبه بهم المعتادين لمحاولة خلق
قضايا أمر واقع على الأرض لا لاجئين
في الأردن ولا لاجئين في
مصر حسنًا أه انظر إلى أهل
غزة الآن  يواجهون خيارين
إما المغادرة أو مواجهة الموت أو
العقاب الجماعي، لذا فهم في الأساس
يخيرون بين
الطرد أو الإبادة بين
التطهير العرقي والإبادة الجماعية ولا
ينبغي منح أي شخص أه أن يواجه
هذا النوع من الاختيار وما
كان عليه زوجي  يشير إلى أن شعب
فلسطين لا ينبغي أن يتم
نقل غزة مرة أخرى، فهم
معظم المرجع معظم أه سكان
غزة هم بالفعل لاجئون وإلى
الآن تم تهجير ما لا يقل عن مليون
من منازلهم لذلك  لا
نريد تهجيراً جماعياً آخر أه
للفلسطينيين مثل ما حدث في
النبا عام
1948 وهذا ما قصده زوجي بأن
هذا خط أحمر
يحق للفلسطينيين
البقاء على أرضهم نعم لأنهم
كانوا قلقين مما يسمى
الترحيل القسري وعدم السماح لك
بالعودة مطلقًا، لقد كان هناك الكثير
من الاحتجاجات في بلدك كما هو الحال في
أجزاء أخرى كثيرة من العالم وقد
أوضحت ما يتشكل
وهذه رواية مختلفة تمامًا عما
يحدث  اعتمادًا على أي جزء
من العالم يأتي الناس منه
وبعض القادة الذين يأتون منه، هناك انحياز أكثر
تحديدًا
للجانبين الذي يحدث تمامًا كما
أوضحت، أو كنت
معتادًا على ذلك الآن ويجب عليك ذلك
قم بإدارة الأمر بالاحتجاج في الشارع حتى
ضد معاهدة السلام لعام 1994، هل أنت
قلق بشأن الغضب
والحرب الأوسع أو عدم الاستقرار الأوسع في
بلدان مثل بلدك أو في بلدان أخرى حول
المنطقة؟ حسنًا، ستشعر بالقلق إذا كان
هناك انقسام ولكننا  نحن
متحدون تمامًا في موقفنا، كلنا نؤمن
بنفس الشيء، كلنا نشعر
بنفس الألم، كلنا نريد أه نفس الشيء
ولذا أعتقد أن هناك الكثير من الوحدة أه
في العالم العربي وكما قلت
هناك  الشعور بأن حياتنا
أقل أهمية، تعلم لماذا عندما
يأتي الناس أه ليمثلوا أه أنت تعرف
القضية الفلسطينية في أعلى المقابلة، يجب عليهم أن يتم
استجوابهم في إنسانيتهم ​​أه، عليهم أن
يقدموا أوراق اعتمادهم الأخلاقية  أعرف
هل تدين ولا نرى أنك تعرف أن
المسؤولين الإسرائيليين يُطلب منهم الإدانة
وعندما يفعلون ذلك، تعلم أن
الناس فقط يقبلون بسهولة حقنا في
الدفاع عن أنفسنا، ولم أر مطلقًا
مسؤولًا غربيًا يقول الجملة
من حق الفلسطينيين  للدفاع عن
أنفسهم وهكذا تعلم أننا
نرى هذا عندما تعلم أنه حتى في معظم
الديمقراطيات، فإن حرية
التعبير هي على ما يبدو قيمة عالمية
إلا عندما ذكرت فلسطين عندما
يتجمع الناس
لدعم إسرائيل، فهم يمارسون حقوقهم  الحق
في التجمع ولكن عندما يجتمعون من أجل
فلسطين يتم اعتبارهم
متعاطفين مع الإرهابيين أو معادين للسامية،
كما تعلمون تعلمون أنكم ترون
هذه المعايير المزدوجة وهي
تخلق الكثير من خيبة الأمل
في العالم العربي وفي الكثيرين.  الذين
يرون الظلم للتو وأريد فقط
أن أؤكد على كريستيان أنه في
نهاية المطاف لا يوجد
حل عسكري لهذه القضية، الحروب لا يتم
الفوز بها أبدًا، هناك دائمًا خسائر من
جميع الأطراف، النصر أسطورة
يصنعها السياسيون  من أجل تبرير
الخسائر الفادحة في الأرواح لا يمكن إلا أن حتى
لو ذهبت إسرائيل وهزمت كل
أه أو قتلت كل عضو في حماس
فماذا لم يتركوا أثرًا من
الذكريات الرهيبة ذكريات مروعة
ستخلق جيلًا جديدًا من أه
المقاومة الأكثر شراسة وأكثر
أه وأكثر عنفًا لأنك تعلم في
نهاية المطاف أنه لا يمكن
الحصول إلا على حل سياسي لهذا الأمر وقد ظل
زوجي
يؤكد دائمًا أنه لا يمكن أن يكون هناك سلام
واستقرار في  الشرق الأوسط بدون
حل سياسي لذلك حتى لو كنت
حليف أه لإسرائيل أم أنك لا تقدم لها أي
خدمة من خلال تقديم الدعم الأعمى لها